what's up everyone welcome back for
another rings of power interview at san
diego comic con 2022. more of the cast
is here you guys are incredible you're
delightful i'm so excited for you all
thank you thank you all right i'm
starting off with a big group question
here so you are working
on one of like the biggest franchises in
on-screen history now i was about to say
film history but you're bringing it to
series format right now and a gigantic
production but can you each tell me
something about it that felt like
intimate and personal whether it's
something that you were able to bring
that made your voice heard or something
where you saw another cast member or
crew member do something that they were
so purely passionate about
can i say it
okay so i am i what really resonates
with me with bronwyn is i was pre-med so
i have a degree in biology i was going
to be a doctor i only started acting in
my mid-20s and she's a healer so we have
that in common and then also she is from
the south lens and her ancestors chose
bad or evil over good and she's sort of
she and her people are trying to redeem
themselves and prove that they can be
trusted and there's sort of this
activist interactivist in her and i'm a
human rights activist so i always think
of bronwyn as sort of a fantastical
version of myself
i'm deeply deeply passionate about like
if i was to be in a fantasy this is who
i would be but wait i am like that is me
so it's bizarre and surreal and
and super cool it's meant to be
my name's lloyd and i'm playing allen
deal and i think it's a really good
question because the the epic nature of
the production as you say this enormous
franchise and you you can easily get
sucked into that as an idea
and then you know we started and we we
rehearsed we we had jd and patrick in
the room we had
in my case we had the the director wayne
with with us and then we just got into
the details and and it's something that
i've done since i was 18 and a
professional actor it's just the same
thing just trying to trying to tell the
same story collectively as truthfully as
we can and that and that all of the all
of the exterior just
just fades away and it's uh that was the
beauty of this the the collaboration and
the sense that this is how we this is
how we make something
when i think about the personal i think
about the fact that i was um shooting at
home i live in auckland and some of the
studios we were shooting in were some of
the places i'd done my first jobs out of
drama school i'd seen those buildings a
million times i'd seen some beautiful
work done in there
but to arrive and to see
the city of newman built on the backlot
was this incredible marriage of the epic
the out of this world and a place you
know that's had my heart for 10 years it
was incredible
and it was shockingly collaborative
they've hired the best craftspeople on
the planet to create these worlds but at
the same time you've got someone like
kate hawley who is a genius who's asking
your opinion
and going to actually listen to you um
she had these beautiful rings
for the king and i think we spoke about
it the other night i didn't know if i
was allowed to say no no of course um
she had these beautiful rings for the
king and they they each have a specific
meaning and a story in themselves and
my comment was but i also want to
illustrate something about his
warrior past and then when i came back
in she had similar rings that when you
make a fist interlock into brass
knuckles like that that level of
collaboration you don't imagine will be
readily available but but it is you're
really part of the conversation and it's
collaboration at its
best
i love that touch about this kind of
stuff all right nesmeen specific
character question for you now i believe
you've described her as strong and
direct and it just made me curious is
there anything about her past
experiences or the people that she
surrounded herself with that have
brought those qualities out in her
i think that's a really great question
she's a bit of an outcast because she's
so strong-minded and strong-willed and
she's a single mother and she's in this
forbidden romance with an elf and she's
sort of frowned on uh by her community
and so she's had to she's been forced to
sort of prove herself and speak louder
and more directly to um have fellow
people and um
yeah i think when you you're sort of
deemed as the outcast and a little bit
crazy like you you know you're frowned
on then you you tend to become a little
bit more sort of
um forceful in the way you you sort of
get your message across speaking of the
elf human relationship
what is something about the two of them
that makes them like natural immediate
partners but then also what is something
about that elf human differentiation
that gives them something that they
still need to to overcome something
that's a little more difficult to
process yeah i mean it's the age age
long sort of forbidden aspect of an elf
and a human are not supposed to be
together um but on the other hand
they're both sort of outcasts they they
feel sort of misplaced among their own
beings you know him as an elf he's not
um he's a poor elf elf and i'm a poor
man's human if you compare like the
south landers to the numenoreans they're
covered in dirt and they're you know
we're
rough and rugged and um he is also sort
of that in his own world and so
that outcastness is uh what draws us
together and but also we have a lot of
deep love and connection to nature he's
obviously an elf so he does and i am a a
herbalist or a healer so i'm surrounded
by by herb so that connects us um but
then we're so so different in the way we
carry ourselves in the way he's so
silent he's like sort of a stable and
calm presence and i'm sort of more i'm
kind of like ruby played by renee
zellweger in cold mountain if you will
okay yeah i have so many follow-ups i
wish we had like hours and hours to talk
right now lloyd for you with a lend deal
you've said that
he's not really someone who wanted this
responsibility so it was making me
wonder if he didn't wind up having this
responsibility thrust on him where would
he have gone in life what did he
envision the best possible life for
himself being well in terms of uh
of where we see him start the series you
know he he is he's this very capable
ship's captain and he's trying to bring
up these three adult children but he's
recently been widowed so so so the
turbulence
within the family uh is something that
he's just trying to calm he's trying to
find calm waters
enjoying my imagery from being a c
nation um but the uh
so so i think it's a it's definitely a
safe haven is what he's seeking and he
gradually gets drawn in he can feel and
i think it's very talking in the idea
that
when when all of these characters you
see it very much in the books and all of
the rings that they suddenly realize
where their fate lies they understand
that they have a fate
um and so it's it's a battle that we all
have as humans between your head and
your heart and where where your heart
your instinct is telling you to go and
where your head might want to in a
different direction so
so that that's that's something of of of
his theme but the fascinating thing to
me about elendil is so so there are
there are a few signposts on the way
that tolkien has given us we have to get
to the you know to the last alliance of
elves of men elendil king gilgallard
along with gallaudet and eldrant but but
how how does he get here but but talking
to fans this week it was just
so so many people have a real possession
of a lindell they
he's a he's a he's like he's a he's a
hero archetype but based on very little
knowledge and i know i posed the
question to a few people that if the
ring was on the other finger and rather
than a sildor getting the ring it was a
lendil that got the ring would he throw
it into the fire and i asked corey olson
who's the who's the the talking
professor this question he goes no and
immediately said it was such an
emotional reaction i was like okay
you're so invested in that and i i i
don't know the answer to that question
but i would ponder or poss it that
tolkien might say it's unknown as to
whether he would because at the moment
of holding that ring
the fall is apparent in every man and
he's a fallible human being so uh yeah
that's that's where i feel with him a
real privilege to play him and a great
responsibility thinking about what if's
like that all right leon for you how
does kevin feel about his father
listen
uh farazan is a great man and i think
human
the sons of powerful kids the children
of powerful people i think
can fall into two categories you could
argue they can try and um match and
outdo their parents or they can coast
with a level of entitlement and i think
he's more in that category at the point
we meet him he's um
you know he's landed him in a position
of incredible privilege he's living in a
golden age he's got everything he's ever
wanted
there's no real um desire for that to go
away and so i think his dad's
frustration with him is that he's kind
of been a parrot he's not bringing any
new ideas to the table because the ideas
of the day have served him really well
personally
and his journey is
one where he's going to have to
interrogate what he stands for and what
he thinks is worth fighting for and what
that fight might actually entail all
right they're gonna make me leave with
you but ben i'm gonna give you my last
question so i know he senses evil more
strongly than anyone else out there
when he senses it who is his go-to
person to tell that to whether it's
someone that will like believe him in
terms of the severity of the evil he
senses or even just someone to you know
get it off his chest so he could talk
about it with someone that's a great
question i think
when he goes to ponder he probably keeps
it to himself it's one of those things
where where's the king oh he's gone for
a stroll oh no
but when it's time for action
and he needs proper counsel he goes to
calibrimbor
they have a shared experience an
understanding of loss and also the
importance
of reinvesting and protecting middle
earth and also something that you're all
talking about
a love of the frailty of mankind
that they're aware of the fallibility of
them but also it's one of the things
that fascinates us
and uh that we love about them i like
that quality quite a bit i could keep
you here all day long but i'm not
allowed so i have to say goodbye
congratulations thank you everyone out
there
thanks for having us
you